I don't know that any of these things
are truths or facts they're all news to
me oh so you're lying to me right now
hello I'm Ryan Johnson and my new
mystery series Poker Face Natasha Leon
plays Charlie kale who can detect lies
just if someone is intentionally lying
that's it the good Folks at peacock
decide to challenge me to a game of two
lies and the truth let's see how I do
this is going to be a disaster
round one Charlie Kale's go-to
accessories are sunglasses and hoop
earrings the first episode is one hour
seven minutes and one second long Adrian
Brody is wearing a blue shirt
when he first appears on screen these
are hard I would say that number two is
true I said
hey
round two Benjamin portrayed detective
Ray Curtis on Law and Order number two
Benjamin is a San Diego native
Benjamin's last name is not actually
Brett
this is designed to ruin my friendship
with Benjamin Bratt there's only one
truth in that whole thing the truth is
law order
that's right I think he is a San Diego
native is that the truth
is Cliff you have a code red round three
episode one references one Natalie Dasha
Polanco runs to the 19th Floor stairwell
after discovering something in the
presidential suite number two while
trying to lock down the building Cliff
calls in a code red
and number three a Charlie's last words
are
I gotta go
it's number three that is true yes
number three I gotta go
this is too stress we've got a cold blue
we've got to lock down all of the X's
now and get a guy on the ground level
stairwell I'm coming down round four
Natasha asks followers not to confuse
her with Charlie kale in her Twitter bio
two she joined Twitter in August 2013.
her pin tweet is the trailer for poker
face
uh I think it's true that she joined
Twitter in 2013.
I'm gonna have to say
three is the truth your PIN tweet is a
trailer for poker face that's cheeky and
meta so
handled final round this is it this is
it all the money is rests on this here
we go
interface's title isn't Ode to Lady
Gaga's hit song two Cliff is featured in
four episodes of Poker Face the slogan
for episode 2's Body Shop gas station is
quote the last mechanic in New Mexico
end quote three is a lie I need to put
on your best poker face
I'm gonna say number two is right
[Music]
you guys it's just I'm done I'm finished
and that's the truth
[__] the catch our mystery of the week
series Poker Face streaming only on
peacock
[Music]